extra extra read all about it five
nights at Freddy's franchise bought by
Disney full cinematic universe plan
Megan spin-off series coming for The
Walking Dead Marvel vs. DC movie planned
for 2022 former reality TV host elected
president man really can't believe
anything you read these days can you
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where today a
show dedicated to concocting half-baked
theories about movies and TV is talking
about the mainstream media lying to you
in other words we've finally reached
theory level conspiracy let's face it
2016 biggest theme in media both
television and online was the issue of
click baiting coming up with
over-the-top hyperbolic extreme
headlines and a shameless attempt to get
people to click that's nothing new it's
always been around you say but what used
to be just a mild annoyance took out a
really sinister tone this year as
clickbait gave way to it's far more
dangerous relative fake news websites
and newspapers blatantly lying to you
and then passing it off as fact just to
get a headline that gets you to click
it's been an especially hot topic in the
aftermath of the presidential election
where the news is now being blamed for
swaying voters suppressing voters
creating scandals and worst of all
outright lying about simple indisputable
facts like which candidate got more
votes seriously you you for a hundred
percent certainty know who got more
votes in this year's election according
to the headlines that's been flipping
back and forth for weeks and when you
can't get a straight answer on something
as objective as how many people voted
for the leader of the free world and
you've got yourself a problem probably
the most high-profile example of this
was Facebook getting hammered over
election stories appearing in people's
newsfeeds that had nothing to do with
the facts so you don't even have to look
to headlines that big for fake news
despite these fear-mongering articles
from supposedly reliable news sources
you're not gonna get Lyme disease from
your Christmas tree the White House did
not bandit ivities scenes from their
Christmas decorations and Fidel Castro
was shock of all shocks not a
professional baseball star now for all
you knew theorists subscribe to the
channel it's our annual tradition near
the end of the year on both game and
film theory to end with a meta Theory
ascent of the Union address about a
major theme of the
your trend in the industry that you need
to know about so why should you care
about this episode when you're here for
another Disney conspiracy or to tell me
that I was wrong about rogue one or to
complain about Doctor Who part three
still not being uploaded well 1 most
importantly because this is real life
and not some fictional movie and 2
because we're all the targets you me
your family my family your friends my
cats because misleading you is big
business and you deserve to be informed
of how everything from the evening news
to your local newspaper to online blogs
is attempting to manipulate the way that
you think and by extension the way that
you act actually have a couple other
theories related to this one that are
specifically about YouTube that are over
on the game series channel right now so
if you haven't seen those click here
check them out so also be links at the
end of the video and if you're a loyal
game theorist coming from over there
welcome my arms are open to you the
theories are just as depressing on this
side of the Internet's now go ahead kick
back and get ready to never trust
anything you ever see online ever again
let's call a spade a spade 2016 was a
sucky year it was a year full of
international crises racial tensions
surprising celebrity deaths and a very
very tense presidential election and all
along it seemed like the meteor was just
going about doing their job of reporting
but ask yourself this how much of what
you see is real even from the sources we
consider to be the most trusted in the
world how is it possible in the
information age to have false stories
get treated as fact is the whole media
machine just asleep at the wheel or
what's really going on here so to
understand media of today we need to
take a stroll down memory lane fake news
is way older than you think dating all
the way back to the mid 1800 when the
first daily newspaper started being sold
by news boys on the street corners think
Newsies it was a lot less singing and a
lot more of newspapers hiring
urine-soaked bums to shout headlines
these news boys literally had to shout
headlines to get people to impulse buy
papers each and every day which meant
one thing the headlines had to be catchy
one might say they had to be clickbait
tea that's right clickbait actually
predates the click once people started
realizing that exaggerated
catchy titles and fun headlines with
sell more papers on the street than
cut-and-dry news stories the age of
yellow journalism began so what's yellow
journalism well if you've read a
facebook newsfeed since since the
Facebook newsfeed became a thing then
you've already probably seen it yellow
journalism is quote-unquote news that's
badly researched mostly guesswork and
has lots of big statements that are
supported by very little fact some of
the most successful papers in this era
were papers like the New York Tribune in
the San Francisco Examiner but what made
these papers stand out from the crowd
was the types of news stories that they
cover you see they specialized in the
sleaze exaggerated gory crime stories
stories about political scandals and
corruption the New York Tribune became
especially successful off of its racist
coverage and strong anti-immigrant
stances sound like anything you've been
reading this year maybe juror doesn't
paint a pretty picture but it definitely
sells newspapers or in the modern case
of digital media gets people clicking
and from there once people have clicked
or bought the paper doesn't really
matter what the content is or whether
the headline was true or not in fact in
the heyday of yellow journalism there
were companies who liked it better if
the story was false because then the
paper could run an expose than an
argument or a bottle or some sort of
angry response drawing out a clickable
headline for more and more papers on
those clickable subjects keeping people
coming back to stay on top of a scandal
that wouldn't have even existed if the
newspaper had done their homework in the
first place which begs the question why
do we have this problem a reporter's
just bad or news outlets just less
selective about the stories they run why
our news companies and TV networks still
going if they're clearly bad at their
job of reporting news well the reason is
that reporting news isn't their job
they're not actually in the news
business they're in the advertising
business most news companies don't make
money from the news they make money from
the ads that are sold alongside the news
reporting on current events is just
filling time giving them content to get
you to watch
and to read so that way you're there
when the next ad starts to slot in these
news companies aren't making money off
of the article they're making money off
of what's above the article and what's
next to the article and popping up over
top of the article and then flashing and
auto-playing in the middle of that
article man the internet looks
completely different when you turn off
your ad blocker I can't understand how
people can use the internet when it
looks like this whoa
so step one is to stop thinking about
the blog's that you read as new sites
because they're not their product isn't
news its advertising space take this
line of thought to its logical
conclusion and you get something that
makes a whole lot of sense when you stop
to consider it YouTube isn't a video
platform it's an advertising platform
Facebook isn't a social site it's an
advertising site that happens to have
pictures of your friends babies to lure
you in Google it ain't making a whole
lot of money off of its search engine or
the new tech that it's producing it's
all about the ad according to Bloomberg
Businessweek 76 point 1 billion dollars
or around 90 percent of Google's income
is coming off of its ad business to cite
a former executive from the company
quote no one wants to face the reality
that this is an advertising company with
a bunch of hobbies creating products
where it can then place ads and news is
just a fancy word for a genre of
entertainment stories that may or may
not be real to get your attention and
sell some commercial breaks in the
process but I hear you rightfully asking
is clickbait actually doing any harm
outside of being mildly annoying nothing
lost but a little bit of time right
wrong it turns out that not only does
the media do a good job of figuring out
how to get people to click on fake news
they do an even better job of getting us
to share that fake news one thing we've
seen a lot of this year is reaction
compilations don't laugh don't cry don't
cringe emotional response is huge on the
internet and that applies just as much
to regular news as it does to YouTube
but not all reactions are created
equally it turns out that after 150
years of media coverage news outlets
have pretty well figured out what
emotions are better at getting people to
share than others so let's look at the
five major emotions as we've been told
by inside outs any guesses as to which
one gets people to spread news the
fastest is it discussed like the
pictures of redneck 80s prom photos or
is it
happiness like all those videos of dogs
greeting soldiers coming back from
Afghanistan I'll stop the Clipper I'm
gonna lose it they get me every time but
I'm not likely to share it because not
even the warm fuzzies can top the most
powerful emotion for fake news anger an
influential study of 200,000 Twitter
users in China conducted by MIT showed
that angry posts on social media are 3
times more likely to be spread through
shares or retweets than any of the other
emotions and if you look back across the
news this year you can see that it's
true what are the top stories that
dominated headlines racial tensions
senseless violence people's rights being
threatened but then look at the posts
that got the most shares reasoned
arguments and analyses aren't the posts
pulling in the big numbers it's the
emotional responses the RAF's
the raging in that moment of anger why
would I check to see if that story is
real the headline is right there and
from a trusted source and is so rage
inducing that I have to share it right
away
it prompts an immediate reaction there's
no time for fact-checking because the
immediate response is to hit retweet to
tell everyone we know about this so that
they can be as enraged as we are because
seriously Scott what are you thinking
Disney is gonna take away all the scary
murdery elements that has made fine ass
is to this day you're diluting the brand
by selling it to Disney man come on and
as you might imagine this starts to get
real dangerous real fast we're in an age
of ripple effect entertainment where one
small post or one small story can
escalate and grow and grow into a much
bigger much more massive much more
dangerous thing a world where one person
posts a fake story on reddit or
manufacturers a fake news image on
Twitter it picks up momentum gets some
up votes some retweets suddenly smaller
blogs are picking it up larger accounts
start to talk about it the hashtag
starts to trend until it's all the way
up to the mainstream media and big-time
news outlets and at that point no one
has actually gone back to check the
original source in fact it's almost
impossible to find that original source
bandwagoning has made it into a reality
if you want a concrete example then look
no further than 2007 in the iPhone 4 the
blog Engadget reported on authority that
the iPhone 4s release date was getting
pushed back from June
to October and potentially later in less
than 15 minutes after that article was
published I kid you not when I say this
apples of value as a company dropped by
four billion dollars four billion
dollars in 15 minutes and as I'm sure
you can guess the Engadget article was a
complete hoax
luckily Apple was able to clarify the
situation and recover most of the lost
money by the end of the day but it just
goes to show how dangerous this stuff
can be here especially when it's
influencing the candidates that we vote
for the way that we choose to spend our
money and the way that we feel about
other people and other cultures so
clickbait and the fake news that it
generates can be a real problem but what
can we do well newspapers have been
dealing with this model for a long time
but way back when yellow journalism was
a problem one of the first big answers
to fake news was designing a system that
wasn't based on selling papers on street
corners anymore it was based on of all
things
subscriptions how was that better well
take for instance the New York Times one
of the first subscription-based
newspapers when they had a
subscribership they could count on the
newspaper no longer had to worry about
whether their headlines were clickbait t
enough to sell to the same customer
every day they had a consistent source
of income that they could rely upon that
in turn let the journalists relax a
little bit enabled them to print more
normal-looking stories and maybe even
spend some time fact-checking for the
subscribers meanwhile they were
supporting a product that they believed
in and that they trusted to deliver
regular content lots of newspapers still
have a subscribership model and it's
exactly because of this if you're
financially supporting the paper it
shouldn't have to rely on sleazy tactics
to stay afloat but okay that's all fine
and dandy for traditional media but a
lot of traditional media is dying and
here on youtube we care about one thing
more YouTube so what's the cure for
clickbait here well actually it's the
same thing YouTube has subscribers
sometimes people I work with ask me why
subscriber numbers matter so much to
creators and really it's for the same
reason as it mattered to the newspapers
youtubers count on subscribers to keep
coming back and supporting the channel
sure those viewers aren't paying a fee
for that subscription but it's a
generally reliable source of income a
system based on trust I trust that those
four million people subscribe to the
channel like the videos that I make and
that a fairly sizable number of those
people will be checking
on every upload that we do so I can make
more of them and in turn you trust that
my videos are gonna be good and so you
keep coming back it's a great system so
when YouTube starts changing the
visibility of our videos to subscribers
and subscriber views drop or they start
implementing new systems like ring the
bell to get notified of everything that
the channel does rather than some of the
things that the channel does well it
presents a big problem because it's
YouTube breaking down that system of
trust
artificially cutting off that line of
communication and throwing YouTube
creators and their fans into this weird
dark area where we can no longer
communicate with each other so as a
result what do you see when that happens
you see more channels turning to click
baits turning to sensationalize titles
turning to the youtube version of yellow
journalism to try and get their videos
seen for just one more day if you can't
count on the stability of the platform
you start resorting to content that's
the lowest common denominator but funny
enough it's also possible that the final
solution is YouTube red yeah that thing
for those of you that don't know or have
successfully triggered it out of your
mind YouTube red is YouTube subscription
service making the site ad free in an
effort to move away from advertising
revenue there's other stuff too like
access to some pretty great shows like
threatened links buddy system oh and I
suppose there's Matt Pats game lab tube
that was all right I enjoyed it all
shameless self-promotion aside when
YouTube launched did we have YouTube
viewers weren't exactly welcoming it
with open arms
reports were piling in both on and off
the site that red would kill the YouTube
community by taking money away from the
creators and that revenue across the
board would drop for everyone but now
ask yourselves this what actual data did
you see in any of those articles was it
rational arguments about what this meant
for the site or was it click Beatty
titles that were designed to make you
feel angry and upset that YouTube was
changing that you were better dead than
red and so you wanted to go out and
share that video because now we can look
back at the data and I can honestly say
across all the channels that I helped
consult it is only increased the amount
of money that they earn above and beyond
what they would be earning in ads anyway
granted the system was and still isn't
perfect YouTube honestly must have hated
me during the lead-up to game lab over
on the game theorist Channel because I
complained about a ton of stuff related
to red but a lot of our fears came
from once again people looking to make a
buck peddling in fear to make a profit
and causing the public to rebel against
a decision that quite honestly helps
creators make better higher quality
projects and if nothing else earns more
revenue per view than they would
otherwise all while helping to stifle
this fake news problem so what do we do
who's gonna fix all this the answer is
no one but us at the end of the day
videos only go where we as the audience
will follow you're viewing choices
matter and they matter a lot
so in 2017 there's no election but vote
with your view knowing when and how
you're being manipulated is half the
battle so support creators who do good
work not just the ones that make you
feel angry or who talk about issues
without any real information we do have
the power here and it's our obligation
to do the research ourselves because as
you've seen no one else is gonna do it
for us but hey that's just a theory one
half of this theory because if you want
to see more click this annotation or the
top line of the description to check out
a different perspective on this issue
over on my channel game theory in that
video which is time to release exactly
at the same time this one comes out I
look at the complaint a bunch of
youtubers had been having about
declining views and we analyzed the real
reasons behind it is it entirely
YouTube's fault or something else the
answer will shock you how's that for a
click Beatty lead-in so anyway click on
the giant flashing ad to go over there
and check it out and hey make sure that
you ring my bell right there that that
Bell thing like I said earlier this
episode the subscription mechanism
working properly is one of the best ways
to combat all of this so ring the bell
and keep your fingers crossed that my
videos continue to show up for you we'll
be back to normal episodes next time but
until then remember that's just a theory
a film theory and cut if you want an
amazing first look at all this check out
the book trust me I'm lying written by
Ryan Holliday who worked inside these
systems and learned how to exploit
templed for his own benefit and for his
clients so I listen to me when the back
of the book says everything you need to
know quote why am i giving away these
secrets because I
tired of a world where blogs take in
direct bribes marketers help write the
news reckless journalists spread lies
and no one is accountable for any of it
I'm gonna explain exactly how the media
really works and quotes
now that doesn't pique your interest I
don't know what will or maybe I do
you